I heard it fast I was thinking calling
myself Pied Piper hey I assigned the
nicknames around here oh that one's not
bad yes I'm a lot faster than a speeding
bullet
yes means a hero
hey youtubers what's up this is gonna be
a breakdown of the new flash footage
it's basically from episodes 10 to 12 so
they'll have like another trailer with
the back half of the season it's like
the next big arc the biggest thing or
like the new characters the new Rogues
so we finally see a good shot of
heatwave he was in the previous trailer
but it was really dark in the scene he
was in this is Pied Piper and this is
probably peekaboo although she's not on
the IMDB page yet so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna talk about each of the
episodes that they appear in there are a
couple other characters that aren't in
this trailer that we'll see like some
minor characters in one really big one
or actually a couple of really big ones
starting with episode 10 revenge of the
Rogues captain cold and heatwave team-up
pretty simple pitch the title is
actually a play on the Geoff Johns
rogues revenge storyline from Final
Crisis it involved the Bart Allen flash
inertia and the hunter zolomon zoom so a
bunch of characters we haven't seen on
the show yet so I'm not expecting a
comic book storyline it'll probably just
be the Rogues kickin flashes but and it
is their first outing as the Rogues like
they just form the Rogues at the end of
episode 4 so this will be the team's
first mission in addition to them we're
gonna see osgood and rachel rathaway in
the comics they're the parents of
hartley rathaway who becomes Pied Piper
this guy they're a wealthy family that
spends a fortune trying to cure their
son's deafness and in the comics Pied
Piper is already a criminal so they
spend their time trying to cover that up
too the show is doing something
different with the character though he's
gonna be part of the STAR Labs team I've
already done a bonus video for heatwave
kind of explaining his comic-book
history so I had a link in the
description they're also a couple of the
characters I've done bonus videos for
that I'll mention in this video so all
those links as well also debuting in
episode 10 this is really big Jason
Rusch we're gonna see him for the first
time I don't know if it's gonna be in a
flashback or in present-day this is the
way the producers explained his
character so he in the show that is is
part of Project firestorm or was part of
Project firestorm with Professor Martin
Stein and Ronnie Raymond so they'll
probably end up using him to push the
firestorm plotline forward it doesn't
mean he's gonna be part of the firestorm
matrix and I don't think that we're
gonna see firestorm in that episode
unless it's an archival footage because
bra B Amell isn't listed on the cast
list whatever is happening episode 10
will explain how Jason Rusch is going to
be tied to Team firestorm episode 11 is
called the sound and the fury this is
part 1 of a
two part Pied Piper story his character
is also gonna be in the next episode
after this fun fact he's actually the
boyfriend of Captain sing both in the
comics and on the show that's Barry's
boss in case people don't know who
captain sing is this guy I'm actually
really interested to see how he reacts
to learning that his boyfriend turns
into a super power criminal surprise
surprise I have superpowers and I'm
going to be using them for evil
moving on to episode 12 so that's more
Pied Piper probably the conclusion of
that storyline we're also gonna see
Martin Stein I don't know if that's
gonna be in a flashback or in
present-day
Robbie Amell is also not on the cast
list so it's possible we won't see
firestorm we also get to meet peekaboo
this girl here in the comics she has
powers of teleportation she's not listed
on the IMDB page but in the comics her
character has a boyfriend named clay
Parker who's stuck in iron Heights
prison he uses her to commit crimes
she's not a super evil character she's
actually really smart so hopefully
she'll end up working with team flash a
little bit if she doesn't end up dying
I think the flash is trying to kill as
few characters as possible because I'm
pretty sure they're gonna get a season 2
and they want to bring some of these
people back and it's hard to do if they
kill them with the exception of weather
wizard they actually they just cast a
new weather wizard on the show it's
gonna be the brother of the first
weather wizard from episode 1 because
they just cast him he's probably not
gonna debut till like after episode 16
or 17 like the back half of the season
so we're not gonna see him for a while
so just forget about him for now
so drumroll now please because we are
going to meet Linda Park in episode 12
she's only a minor character but I think
she's gonna get tied up with the iris
West storyline in the comics she's a
reporter
iris West is going to be a reporter on
the show so that's probably where we're
gonna meet her like in that space
wherever iris ends up going to work for
those that haven't read the comics Linda
Park is a huge character she ends up
marrying Wally West they end up having a
flash family like a literal flash family
they haven't made any definitive
statements about Wally West showing up
so I'm not expecting him till season 2
season 3 Linda Park is just laying the
groundwork for that they're just like
they're creating the flash universe like
populating it with all these side
characters so that the big ones can come
in later and yes I know a lot of people
are asking how are they gonna do Wally
West because iris doesn't look like she
has a brother I think it's gonna be a
cousin from out of town like Wally will
be a her cousin for
out of town if he's someone who just
visits every once in a while it'd be way
to explain why he's not in every single
episode because if he has flash powers
too how come he and Grant Gustin
don't talk all the time that's just
speculation though I don't I don't think
we're gonna hear more about Wally West
for a long time maybe Comic Con this
summer maybe they'll mention more about
while it was two people asked them
they're pretty good about answering
questions aside from that there's just a
couple fun Easter eggs in the trailer
one is Barry saying faster than a
speeding bullet
just another Superman joke obviously not
expecting to see Superman or Batman on
either of the shows either arrow or the
flash anytime soon marc guggenheim did
say he really wanted to bring batman on
arrow though but that i think that would
be like a series finale thing I'll talk
more about it when I post my arrow
trailer video and the other thing was
Cisco just saying I'm the one that gives
the names here at this point where the
flash is they've done such a good job
with the Cisco character and all the
little quirks and anachronism that he
has that Gotham recently did the same
thing with the Riddler's character like
he named another super villain and I was
like oh that's a Cisco thing like it's
like Cisco's thing now anytime on any
show when a character gives somebody
else a superhero name I'm just gonna
think of Cisco so just like I said
there's an arrow trailer with just the
same amount of footage I'll do the exact
same type of video for that next be sure
to subscribe to get it
agent Carter had a really strong debut
but I still feel like the flash and
arrow are the most fun shows to watch
like the most fun comic book shows I
won't say best because my opinion always
changes from week to week just depending
on how the episodes are but while you
guys wait for the arrow video click here
to learn more about some of the Rogues
that we're gonna meet this season or
this year and click here to learn all
about the reverse-flash in the comics
thank you so much for watching everybody
high five I'll see you tonight
you